martin schurr young and old with softer in
africa a good team den 1
no here even if people become
active politicians crisis is never going
to be you and livia von photos rating
datatec loosli how did s table democracy
i think the ceasefire that has been in effect since
sunday  in libya is a
step forward
the country and the people need that
however we have heard a
lasting peace
the federal government and especially the
chancellor have been supporting activities for a
long time to create a
lasting peace in
libya and this conference he
commissioner which as far as i know
will take place on
next sunday in berlin is supposed
to make an active contribution
with politi linie
why achieved